hello ladies like it's so sparkly and
lovely I'm sorry I'm just obsessed with
those shoes matte jacket and that
sweater alright back to the movie there
we go for me and someone who's very much
not an actor the idea of playing scared
or terrified seems like one of the
harder emotional places to access and
I'm curious what are your approaches to
it individually um I look speaking on it
I really think like actual fear is it is
one of the hardest to portray because
think you can make yourself sad you can
make yourself happy but like actually
making yourself authentically terrified
because how often are you that terrified
right well yeah um but it was nice we
got to use each other a lot and we did
help each other kind of get there and
yeah think about things and look at her
yeah I like to personally use like
physical things trick my body into it so
I look like a crazy person I just kind
of run in place get my heart racing and
then think about something something I'm
sad to layer it with here and then I'll
try to sometimes I'll use something from
real life and then use will then use the
circumstance that's in the movie to kind
of get into it if that makes any sense
it does you're kind of everybody looked
at me and I feel like you're kind of the
the old pro after haunting of Hill House
was it easier for you to get into that
territory now or so hard it's you know
it's still hard it's not very hard yes
it's it's still difficult I mean I think
that it's gonna be difficult no matter
what because like they said you're never
really that terrified and in real life
and if you are I'm worried but it's I
think that it's still gonna be hard no
matter how many times we get to play
scared or be terrified in movies it's
just one of those things that you never
really quite get used to yeah so if the
very scary days were the hard ones maybe
on set what was sort of the most fun day
on set
there's one day in particular McCann I
got to wear rollerblades which was
really fun because it's just like
rollerskating now it was classic 70s
it's just fun it was a blast to see her
having fun too to see me having fun so
changing not crying in a corner this was
so morbid but fun for me is doing
challenging stuff um so I loved the days
right it sounds so bad where I got to
traumatize myself but um it's not I
enjoy them too actors yeah yeah we like
torturing ourselves yeah whoa yeah
but every scene with with them when we
got to just hang out and enjoy each
other's company as characters was fun
because it's real chemistry most of the
time we were hanging out and enjoying
each other as like they had characters
and stuff we were sitting in a room like
a dark room crying all together so you
guys you know you worked with Gary on
his directorial debut and I'm just
curious what what is his particular vibe
and his element that he brings to the
equation is a filmmaker he's an awful
person
oh my god he booth he smashed a slinky
dog fools to be fair you know but I
write I love Mr curry I think that he
has a really great vibe on set and I
think that he's a wonderful writer and
director though you're still like he
also has this like his whole aesthetic
he's just so 70s and cool and I think
you've really feel in the movie too like
our music in the movie is top-notch and
it's all geared like Gary is a genius
and he's so collaborative - he's one of
the most collaborative directors he's
like right there if you have any
questions per like I did truly loved
loved loved loved working with it yeah